foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ers
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind
you'll know my business yes
power is about strength
if you show weakness you will give our
enemies an opening
[Applause]
he is weak like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you're some kind of Honor we
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting foreign
[Music]
Mr tagline
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
your goddamn lunatic oh you just figure
that out now
foreign
each one of us don't you want to know
why they call me the rhino
[Music]